[Music]
what do you mean lookout Beliebers
justin is reportedly engaged he's really
funny we have a good time together he's
just really sweet he's a good kid he's a
good heart and I love him according to
multiple reports the Biebs popped the
question - Haley Baldwin in the Bahamas
I've had dreams about it long dreams TMZ
reports the two were spotted at a
restaurant where everyone was salsa
dancing the pop star security detail
told everyone there to put their phones
away because something special was about
to happen
that's when Justin reportedly got down
on one knee following the event his dad
Jeremy took to Instagram with a post
that appears to reference the engagement
reading proud as an understatement
excited for the next chapter his mom
also tweeted with an abundance of love
in a tweet that was later deleted
Hayley's dad Steven shared happiness for
JB and HP as well as a congratulations
to Justin's parents the couple has been
spotted together constantly since
rekindling their romance roughly a month
ago I've gotten to a place where I have
like a core group and people who are
really supporting me and encouraging me
[Music]
[Applause]